I want to make sure that when the
republican party loses terribly too in
my opinion the worst president in
American history I want them to make
sure this because they systematically
shut out the most intelligent most
active and youthful voting bloc in
American history hi I'm Zach why smaller
with reason TV we're here at the Tampa
State Fairgrounds with the die-hard Ron
Paul fans waiting for paul fest Paul
Fest is the grassroots celebration of
sort of the end of the twenty twelve
round Paul campaign it is not done with
the cooperation or attendance of Ron
Paul or the official Ron Paul machine
how do you feel like the Ron Paul
faction has been treated by the
Republican Party this time around I mean
definitely as the outcast we are playing
by the rules okay that's why the other
side is so frustrated you feel like the
other side is not playing by the rules
they're changing the rules by the minute
the few people have talked to here so
far seem to be pretty frustrated with
the Republican Party right now can you
explain where that frustration is coming
from it's largely coming from what we've
seen in the last couple of weeks with
the fights over whether Ron Paul's
various state delegations would be
seated it was a kangaroo court I came
down here as a delegate thinking we
could have a conversation about rules
platform procedures and and may be
brought into the campaign and you know
get some of our planks you know accepted
and but you know they made clear
yesterday that they perceive us more as
a nuisance than potential allies during
the state convention we got railroaded
we didn't end up getting seated at the
convention here in Tampa let intelius
participate and actually have a voice
instead of just scripting the whole
thing like it already is Romney is
probably lost even some of the support
he might have had there is definitely a
very bad taste in the mouth about Romney
and about the official Republican
political machine if you even want to
imply that we are involved in some kind
of common cause with a monster like Mitt
Romney that you have missed the whole
point of the Ron Paul revolution
I'm not planning on scoring Mitt Romney
why not well after seeing the tactics
employed by his campaign yesterday you
know really upset me there's no way I
could support someone like him how does
this affect your attitude towards the
Republican Party it makes me feel like
they are a bunch of idiots you can
reform the Republican Party if you want
to look at the way the Republican Party
is treated Ron Paul if Romney wins the
nomination I'll be supporting Gary
Johnson Gary Johnson's campaign is
making a very intelligent bid for the
Ron Paul voter he's not afraid to come
here and ask for the Ron Paul vote will
show the world and the nation that what
Ron Paul has stood for is not a fluke
it's the future live free live prey the
frustration I think can get focused in a
way that will have an impact in this
election and that would be voting for me
to say that they'll go third party yeah
I think nobody in the Ron Paul movement
really wants to see Barack Obama or Mitt
Romney get the the presidency you know
we're pretty much libertarians and we'll
go the route to the person who believes
closest to us you're suspicious of the
media well I'm suspicious the media well
we don't call it lame stream media for
nothing I'm not part of the mainstream
media I said lame stream I am part of
the lamestream media
haha